Adam Carolla's first ever stand-up
special not Taco Bell material which is
a great story in itself because I do
know that you were not hired by Taco
Bell that is pretty [ __ ] amazing
you did get hired by McDonald's but Taco
Bell said you are not Taco Bell
materials that the quote that is the
quote what the [ __ ] was the problem I
mean you're a very smart guy you were
reasonable you know you're I'm sure
you're a hard worker why would they
evaluate is there something about you we
don't know there was a Taco Bell walking
distance to my dad's house in North
Hollywood I lived in in 1979 and I
walked over there and I filled out an
application and they said they were
hiring and they just rejected it doesn't
that crush you as you maybe like there's
something about you that Taco Bell felt
was disturbing it sort of emotionally
when I was 15 and a half in terms of
Taco Bell rejecting my application in
terms of soul-crushing and and how that
felt to my psyche it was debilitating
but it needed to get in line there are a
thousand other things women didn't like
me my parents didn't like me I wouldn't
you love to see the sheet of paper where
the guy wrote listen this guy's [ __ ]
disturbed or this guy looks odd or you
know I would just love to be like I
failed something it wasn't like there's
a bell B for assembly test handy doing
under 30 seconds was merely based on
your your whatever you said and what you
look like no I know I as I think back on
it I realized what happened hi this is
play do I was functionally illiterate
like that application looked like a note
from the [ __ ] Unabomber hasting
letters from newspapers and sticking
their maybe whoever if you would look at
my printing when I was 15 you know you
had a problem like I'm left-handed my
penmanship was horrible I'm function
illiterate I couldn't spell the computer
because everybody writes one another's
yeah I mean you do have spellcheck but I
mean things get bad yeah so I think it
was based on that later on I got a job
at McDonald good for you yeah so it all
worked out